we have exciting news about a Sunday
tradition that is close to my heart here
on CBS Margaret Brennan has been named
the new moderator of Face the Nation
we're all very happy about that she will
also continue her role as senior foreign
affairs correspondent for CBS News
Margaret has reported on the White House
international affairs in global markets
and we're excited to have her join us
here she's on the Face the Nation sat in
Washington Margaret good morning and
congratulations yeah good morning thank
you very much this looks familiar right
it looks familiar and it looks very
comfortable and right in place and it's
a great team there let me ask you this
Margaret the the gun control debate is
going the president has weighed in a
little bit seeming to inch perhaps a
little bit away from the NRA where do
you think he really is on this policy
inch is the right word there because to
be honest with you the White House is
still trying to figure out where the
president's heart is on this issue they
are not clear yet on their messaging
they're calling this a two-week
listening session a lot of it is going
to be designed to buy time to see not
just what's practical what the president
really wants to do but what's going to
be possible are they waiting out a new
cycle or are they actually going to come
up with some policy prescriptions here
and and as you've been talking about the
president has shown just a slight little
bit of daylight there with the NRA by
saying he wants to raise age
restrictions to 21 in terms of
purchasing weapons but on a lot of these
other issues he's not calling for a
weapons ban and we want to talk through
some of these things on Sunday's program
because as I know you've been talking
about things feel a little bit different
with the kind of activism we're seeing
does it actually result in anything
different this time that's what I was
gonna say Margaret yeah everybody says
that this is different because these
kids are in your face and they're angry
and they're in a lot of pain but what
does the chances do you really think
we're real movement here well you've got
to get Congress back to work to even
fully answer that question but right now
it really looks like some of these
things that the president is talking
about aren't new laws there are sort of
new regulations there are some questions
even about the legality of the things
that he has asked the ATF and Justice
Department to look into in terms of
regular
bump stocks what can he do what is he
willing to do from the executive office
and this conversation seems to be
shifting to one about purely school
safety not as much about gun control
when you do hear the president speak
publicly on this whether it was with
those state and local officials
yesterday or before that with students
themselves and this controversial idea
of arming what they are saying could be
twenty percent or so roughly of
educators or staff in schools who have
weapons training isn't something that
necessarily works each and every time
you could say if you look at just what
happened in Florida with the first
responder in that case being armed and
not entering the school to take down the
active shooter so we're gonna try to
talk through that with some of the
survivors of past school shootings on
Sundays program as well well Margaret
before you go you should know and I know
you know this you're in very good
company lesley stahl Bob Schieffer John
Dickerson and you Margaret Brennan what
are you most looking forward to as you
take over the reigns of Face the Nation
well I'm really looking forward to
carrying on the tradition that they have
laid out in having conversations try to
bring the same kind of intellectual
curiosity that John brought to this
program every Sunday to really have
people walk away with a civil
conversation to actually learn something
because I think all of us and I know all
of you hear it when you talk to people
these days there's so much noise there's
so many headlines and to take some
perspective to say here's what you
actually need to know and what could
actually happen here policy wise is what
I hope will continue to do with the show
Margaret we are all cheering you on and
thrilled for your new job thank you so
when when we got John you got faith yeah
that's right girl take good care of you
as she did me Sunday on Face the Nation
Margaret will speak with Connecticut
governor Dan Malloy who led his state
through the Sandy Hook tragedy that's
Sunday here on CBS